Did you see that python that they
found in the middle of the everglades?
It was 17 feet long. I was
so I googled it. I saw,
this is one of the things I told her. I
said, I was talking about exotic pets.
I googled it.
They get to 30 feet long.
It's ridiculous. Then so then I went down
a whole, I did. I saw that python hall,
the rec record,
17 foot long python carrying 73 eggs
captured in Florida's everglades.
The reason we should
just get rid of Florida,
snap it off and push it into the ocean.
There's too much craziness
happening there. Fucking snake.
Now here's the thing that freaked me out.
I found out those snakes
get twice that length,
so this has only been going on apparently
for like the last 15 or so years.
They apparently didn't have a real
population of pythons in the everglades.
15 years ago. Somebody's pet get loose.
That thing at 73 eggs. I know. No,
it didn't get loose. Some asshole
just released his snake, right?
Someone just chucked it out the window
and then it fucks up the balance of the
ecosystem.
They escape from a breeding facility
destroyed by Hurricane Andrew in 1990 to
100% oh horror movie starts starts.
Great horror movie.
Somebody write that script.
Tens of thousands of Burmese pythons are
estimated now we live in the area and
that's just now they've completely wiped
out all the raccoons, all the skunks,
all the rabbits. It's almost no man. I'm
out. Yeah, they're eating alligators now.
Nice.
Those things eat alligators.
That's a video to see shit shoulder.
There's a photograph of one that died
because the alligator chewed its way out
of its body.
Nature is so brutal,
so God damn ruthless, but there's some
beauty in that ruthlessness. Just that,
just that like undying desire for survival
that exists in creatures like that,
that can't, there's no
empathy. There's no sympathy.
They're just going to eat their way
out of you to survive. You have,
there's something cool about as long
as it's not your five year old kid that
gets snatched. Absolutely. That's a
goddamn nightmare. This show this,
but this just for you guys,
is this one doing this isn't eating and
you look at that as a different one.
I think this is an Anaconda and a
Cayman says python eats alligator alive.
It's the whole thing.
I mean it's the whole thing alive.
Is that a python for sure. Yeah, it
seems like it is. It seems like it is.
That's actually a video of me eating a
grilled cheese and 2:00 AM looking at o
two it is sped up, but look how it gets
all the way down to the fucking tail.
That is amazing.
I wonder if snakes have taste buds or if
it's just for pure hunger to just stop
and think about what
we're looking at here.
This snake just ate a whole alligator.
There goes a tail.
Oh my tenants body and it's just going
to break it down. Look at the eval.
Chill.
Because they're vulnerable when they eat
that he's got to go and just hide it.
Hide under a canopy. Well that's why
there's like snakes everywhere on earth.
Well now there are in Florida.
Yeah.
But I mean they're not
everywhere because if they,
they really could just eat and then go
out and eat again like real quick like,
oh look how aligned could,
right it would be it.
They would eat all the
ecosystem would be destroyed.
They need to buy everything
where the alligator chewed
its way out. Look at that.
Also kind of bad ass of that alligator.
It looks like the tail popped out.
Even see what's going on.
Maybe the tail, you know,
cause those tails are very strong and
they're so thick. It's like an armor.
Go to that website. Ah, that's wild man.
Jesus Christ is really wild.
But that's just shows you how
hungry these fucking things are.
They've eaten everything that's out
there but also their masters, their,
their ability to capture
something and then kill it.
That's that vicious Brian.
An alligator.
Like those are kind of hard to sneak
up on and capture and hold on to.
I don't think they are. I
think you don't think so? No.
I think that's one of the reasons
why it could get it so quick.
I think they just lay
around most of the time.
I think alligators don't tweak because
they don't have any natural enemies until
the pythons came along. I think
because they're so bad ass. Yeah.
I don't think they're equipped for this.
Yeah.
They're probably not equipped for your
Pi. Right. Where they're just there. The,
the snake found a vulnerability
in the system. He was like, Oh,
I'm going to snack on alligators.
Wonder how long it takes a snake with
this nasty gut juices to break down
alligator hide. Three, three, three days.
Three to four days. That's my guess.
I'm gonna say at least a week to break
down all of that. Maybe even longer. Yeah.
It's got to have some gnarly like acids,
acids in its stomach to break that down.
Yeah.
Some Shit like from the movie alien.
Yes.
Like battery acid just
burns right through it.
Why aren't we like using snake acid
to break down rust on cars and stuff?
We should be looking into that.
Yeah. I would clean up everything.
Probably would clean up everything.
And the animated recreation of the
Python alligator battle suggest that the
python might have survived.
It's a massive meal.
But that a second gator came to the
rescue and bid off the snake's head. Oh,
was that the alligators bitch
being like the force of the tussle,
the new theory says is what
caused the python. Wow. Whoa.
So alligator came and fucked him
up after he ate an alligator.
Homie came and rescued him.
They have any homeys really no assholes.
I think they're assholes with tiny little
brains and they just shoot things in,
suck them down.
They just fuck reptilian style.
Did you ever see that video
of the crocodiles and they
go to feed them and uh,
it was on my Instagram,
Jamie,
the one with the crocodile through slave
nation goes to throw some chicken out
for the crocodiles and the crocodile
snap up the chicken and one crocodile
reaches over to the guy next
to him and bites his leg,
bites the crocodiles leg
and it just rolls. Oh God.
Snaps it off and checks it down.
Swallows it. And the other alligator,
the other crocodile rather
that doesn't even budge.
You just got his arm bit off is
like, what happened? Oh my fuck.
This is when you realize what these
things are. They don't give a fuck there.
It's so crazy to watch.
They're dinosaurs doesn't even freak
out that its arm got bitten off and
swallowed by his name.
I will say if I'm eating a
really delicious sandwich
and someone bites me and
gonna be like, I'm just going to finish
the sandwich. I have to be honest.
How hungry are you if you're very
hungry? Well, he's not even finishing.
He's lying there and the other allergy
or these little crocodile bites his leg
and then rips it off. Watch this. That
sounds this shit. Just watch it. Boom.
Now Watch.
They've run in.
See this one's snacking up and look grabs
it and the watch gator roll def snaps
it off, chucks it down.
Go. But look at him.
He doesn't even do anything.
What the fuck bro?
He just lost his leg and he's like,
what the fuck bro?
I mean those are not regenerative, right?
Yes they are. Can you grow another Paul?
Yep. Whoa. Yeah, they, they, they
grow other pots all the time.
Yeah.
That is so wild.
GATOR DNA on my face.
I bet you that's really good for just
like keeping your shit fresh or you look
like scales. You want that. That'd
be kind of cool. Forever scales.
That'd be a superhero I
could probably capitalize on.
It does not need to worry about
what you look like. Right.
Just scales to your face.
Boom.
Two there and right now I'm not going
to wear any rouge. I got scales.
I'm gonna go out. Some girl had to be
the first girl to get a face tattoo.
You could be the first girl to get skills.
Probably some.
Probably a really long time ago.
Somebody just got a face tattoo. Well,
most tribal. Yeah, most
likely tribe tribal.
Maybe like one of those polyandrous
tribes. What does this Jamie,
that's what it looks like. A snake.
The I'll get her inside of it. Yeah.
It does take three days for it
to break down the they scientist.
Dr Your at her watch out.
I'm a doctor and a scientist.
I know all about gut assets. I know
about gut acids because I'm Italian.
I've got Agita. I've been
hurt. God, you didn't forever.
It is a real thing. That's science.
That's the Caelian science guy. He's good.
The fucking,
you know what's crazy?
The everglades is,
if this is how it is now,
imagine what it's going to be like 20
years from now when these things just keep
breathing. Yeah, it's gonna take,
it's gonna take a few generations
for that to balance back out.
They need to put some wolves in that area
and get it all back to where it should
be. Well, they have
crocodiles in there now too.
There's been confirmed sightings of Nile
crocodiles, not American crocodiles,
Nile crocodiles for the same. That's wild
where the alligators are. That's fucked.
It's fucked because those are the
ones that eat zebras and shit.
Everything they're going to be
eating, watch, hide. Your kids hide.
Your wife know they don't.
Definitely.